today's announcement brings
unprecedented clarity and visibility
into the universe with targets ranging
from nearby stars
relatively nearby exoplanets and some of
the most distant galaxies and clusters
of galaxies known to exist
after careful planning for these images
scientists working
on the james webb space telescope didn't
quite know what to expect
why do some of the galaxies in this
image
which is a very small subset of the
hubble deep field how do they appear
bent in arcs well it's the combined mass
of the galaxy both luminous matter and
dark matter that causes gravitational
lensing just as albert einstein's theory
of general relativity predicted a
hundred years ago
and this magnifying effect of a lens is
identical to an optical lens that you
might be familiar with except it's
gravity doing the lensing it's
magnifying a galaxy that we might not be
able to see from the farthest galaxy in
this image it's over
13.1 billion years of travel time away
from us traveling at the speed of light
the karina nebula or ada carina it's one
of the largest and brightest nebulae in
the sky it's over 7 000 light years away
in the constellation karina which you
can only see from the southern
hemisphere and i had the amazing
opportunity to glimpse through a six
meter diameter telescope called the
magellan telescope in 2019
shortly before the great eclipse and the
southern hemisphere and i looked through
the telescope and where was it pointed
to the ada carina nebula home to many
massive stars most of which are much
much larger than our sun
it's an amazing nebula of a cloud of gas
and dust with rich treasure troves of
data for astronomers and these data
aren't the only glimpse that astronomers
will take we plan to study these objects
for decades to come
also in the south the southern ring
nebula or the 8 burst nebula is what's
called a planetary nebula an expanding
cloud of dust that comes off is puffed
away from a dying star
this object is nearly a half a light
year in diameter and it's over 2 000
light years away from the earth
the southern ring nebula
is fascinating
the dimmer dying star is expelling gas
and dust that webb sees in unprecedented
detail
it saw it with two different instruments
on the telescope that we'll explore in
more detail
on the left in this image is near cam's
image and on the right is miri's image
and they both provide different types of
information
the southern ring nebula
despite being called a planetary nebula
doesn't have anything to do with planets
at all
these are shells of gas and dust shed by
dying sun-like stars this will be the
fate of our sun as well
that kind of belch out the outer exo
atmosphere of the star not the planet
new details from webb will further
transform our understanding of how stars
evolve and the mysteries they contain
going farther out into space
290 million light years away
jwst imaged stefan's quintet located in
the constellation pegasus
this quintet of galaxies is notable for
being the first compact group ever
discovered by astronomers way back in
1877. can you imagine what those
astronomers would think if they could
glimpse these images today
four of the five galaxies in the quintet
are locked together gravitationally
bound to one another as they play out
the bulk of eternity in gravitational
embraces
and lastly we come
to
a very interesting object an exoplanet
known as wasp-96b
is a giant planet located far away from
our solar system and it's made mostly of
gas a gas giant
this object this exoplanet is more than
a thousand light years away from earth
and it orbits its host star about a
hundred times more rapidly than earth
rotates around the sun
this massive planet has about half the
mass of jupiter and it was only
discovered about eight years ago
and what's interesting is these data
aren't of the surface of the planet but
actually of the spectrum the spectrum
that we call a library of light
webb captured the light curve of the
brightness of wasp 96b's parent star
over a fairly long period of time
and as the planet transited the star's
disk it's kind of like a little eclipse
a total eclipse though it is not
only a tiny bit of the light from the
star gets blocked
though many of the aspects of this wasp
96b planet were known webb has added
incredible detail thanks to the
spectroscopy results that it provides
you can think of spectra as barcodes in
some sense and these barcodes are
telling scientists that there is an
unambiguous signature of water
present in the haze and the clouds
themselves it's the most detailed
exoplanet spectrum to date it tells us
about the chemical composition of this
planet so what exactly will james webb
be looking forward to in the future
probably more like these images pretty
pictures but also spectra and that is
where most of the rich data that i'm
looking forward to is going to come from
[Music]
the universe is full of light
light that has enabled a treasure trove
of discoveries and images that never
fail to take our breath away as exciting
as these pictures and images are the
data from the james webb space telescope
contains far more information than just
a pretty picture
in fact hiding in plain sight is a vast
library of light and today i'll take you
on a tour of the james webb space
telescope how it works and what
spectroscopy tells us about the very
underpinnings of our universe
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you're new to my channel welcome i'm
brian keating chancellors distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california san diego i'm also an
experimental cosmologist who builds
telescopes and takes them all around the
world to far-flung places like the south
pole
chile
and even shoot some telescopes deep into
space
today's exciting discoveries from the
james webb space telescope or jwst are
providing a new rosetta stone for
astronomy and cosmology and i'm going to
take you on a deep dive into how it all
works
today's announcement involves exoplanets
fascinating objects perhaps harboring
life
today's announcement describes new
phenomena like the earliest galaxies and
stars in the entire universe helping us
understand how our galaxy got here and
perhaps how life on earth could possibly
form
many telescopes have been launched into
space and even with our most advanced
earth-bound telescopes we've only seen
slivers of the expansive universe
including some faraway galaxies
but not nearly as far away as those
discovered by the james webb telescope
telescopes in space like the web are
unbound by the earth's atmosphere
this allows them to see much better than
their earthbound telescope cousins
but these telescopes are encumbered by
other constraints such as size weight
and operational support in distant
regions as far as a million miles away
from earth four times the distance from
the earth to the moon
and of course in space no one can hear
you scream
but there's also no prospect to fix a
telescope located so far away
the web telescope is 4 000 times farther
away from earth than the hubble
telescope there's no prospect to ever
get repaired
there have been over 90 space telescope
launched over the past half century
these have been finely tuned to see
aspects of the universe in ever more
detail the most famous space telescope
of course is the hubble space telescope
named after edwin hubble and designed by
lyman spitzer at princeton university
way back in the 40s it was unleashed in
1990
over 32 years ago
of course it was named after edwin
hubble who in the 1920s discovered not
only the existence of other galaxies for
the first time but also that those
distant galaxies were expanding getting
ever farther away from us with each
passing year
32 years after hubble launched a worthy
successor has seen first light and
obtained
stunning new images and data the james
webb space telescope over two decades
and 10 billion dollars in the making
the jwst is the fruition of one of the
most ambitious international science
collaborations ever undertaken
it is arguably one of the most complex
precise machines ever built
on a par with the large hadron collider
which cost about the same amount except
this telescope was launched a million
miles away from earth unlike the lhc
after being delivered to its parking
space by a european space agency ariane
5 rocket in late december 2021
by
march of this year 2022 it had reached a
million miles distance from the earth it
unfolded flawlessly and synchronized its
orbit with that of the earth around the
sun
protected by five tennis court sized
heat shields
these heat shields allow webb's
instrumentation to achieve a frosty
50 kelvin or minus 370 degrees
fahrenheit
below zero forever under careful mission
control from engineers on earth
the web unfolded 18 hexagonal mirrors
and align them to within a tolerance
smaller than a human hair to comprise a
giant 6.5 meter diameter primary mirror
with a collecting area over six times
greater than that of the hubble
telescope
resulting in the first stunning image
alignment images to be sure calibration
images as they're known but these images
revealed the presence of untold galaxies
lurking in plain sight that were hidden
to the hubble space telescope by virtue
of the fact that the hubble space
telescope cannot access the long
wavelength light that the webb telescope
is designed uniquely to receive
some sources of light originated at the
dawn of time when the very first
galaxies were born over 13 billion years
ago just a few hundred million years
after the origin of our observable
universe
now the images as startling as they are
don't contain the entirety of
information to get that we need to
explain what spectroscopy is james webb
has cameras that can see into a huge
swath of the near and mid infrared
spectrum ranging from wavelengths as
short as 0.6 micrometers or microns in
wavelength which is visible to the human
eye to 28.5 micron wavelengths much
farther beyond both what the human eye
could see and the one or two
micron wavelengths that the hubble space
telescope could see
as the universe expanded
objects are pushed to what are called
higher and higher redshifts meaning that
the wavelength originally which may have
been in the visible wavelength of light
has been redshifted far outside
potentially as far as 28 microns almost
the highest redshifts that could
possibly be observed this high
wavelength capability allows the web to
penetrate clouds of dust and gas that
populate the universe
and in these highly redshifted parts of
the spectrum the web's near infrared
instrument and near infrared camera are
giving the world stunning images of
galaxies from the dawn of time that may
reveal how the very first stars were
formed and how those stars gathered into
the first galaxies and what is pulling
the universe together on small scales
dark matter and what is causing the
universe to expand and accelerate in its
hubble expansion
the so-called dark energy effect now
most telescopes that you're familiar
with including telescopes that i've
recommended you purchase on this channel
in previous videos
are designed to produce pretty pictures
images and even images can provide a lot
of data but far more information comes
from spectrographs images of the
spectrum detected by the web telescope
that reveal the distances and the
composition of objects producing the
light
spectroscopy is the ability to read the
library of light that fills our universe
teasing out its secrets
if a picture is worth a thousand words
as the saying goes a spectrum is worth a
thousand pictures
i think of it as putting a chemistry set
right at the objects you're interested
in right back at the beginning of time
and assaying the composition the
chemical makeup the chemical
fingerprints of the oldest objects ever
seen to exist webb has three exquisitely
sensitive spectroscopic instruments the
near infrared spectrograph or near spec
the mid infrared spectrograph
and the slitless spectrograph
the near spec is a micro mechanical
marvel
that has the ability to observe a
hundred different objects simultaneously
using an array of over one quarter of a
million tiny little mirrors that are
only 100 by 200 micron diameter shutters
this combination of spectroscopy
instrumentation will not only analyze
the composition of distant stars and
galaxies
but it has also revealed the composition
and atmosphere of exoplanets
over 4 000 of which
have been already cataloged by previous
instruments like the kepler space
telescope
webb may confirm that some of these
exoplanets have conditions in their
atmosphere that either indicative are
indicative of life or that prove they
already harbor life
so what are the implications of what
jwst has shown us in its first images
is there something new are they just
more detailed views of previously
discovered phenomena
astronomers will compete feverishly for
time on this incredible new instrument
and they'll pour over the images and the
spectral data collected for decades to
come
i will try to involve you my audience
with these astronomers in live streams
and conversations describing the
findings on a near real-time basis so
join me and subscribe to the channel to
get access to exclusive conversations
with these titanic astronomers
the discoveries announced today will
reverberate for decades and new
discoveries await us as well the nature
of primordial black holes
what was the earliest black hole that
could possibly form in the universe
new discoveries about atmospheres
surrounding distant exoplanets and
fascinating glimpses into the very first
stars and galaxies that ever formed
webb's findings will continue to stoke
your curiosity and i'll be right there
to help you interpret them leave a
comment below which discovery by james
webb are you most excited to learn about
don't forget to subscribe and join my
mailing list for twice monthly updates
from around the universe of cosmology
experimental particle physics and beyond
visit brianketing.com
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
undoubtedly for the decades to come data
releases from the james webb space
telescope will keep us enthralled and
entertained and i'll be right here
guiding you through and explaining the
significance of these amazing findings
by colleagues all around the world stay
tuned for a special video on thursday
morning with the james webb space
telescope project scientist john mather
a man who's already won a nobel prize a
man who has committed his career to
understanding and unraveling the
mysteries of the universe
don't miss your chance to chat live with
john mather winner of the nobel prize
and project scientist for the james webb
space telescope this thursday